I know that [ __ ] doesn't play
dude he's a gorilla he's a gold ruler
all the top guys oh yeah got to salsa
and regalo doing Deb yes garage let me
ask you this is it better to just let
the dead I was gonna ask you because of
that when he dead lives he's left is
that best way to do it you tell me I
don't know [ __ ] I don't know [ __ ] either
yeah I would always think that the
negatives are important I mean negatives
for me are very important like for
chin-ups I go way slower it seems like
every six months there's a whole new
philosophy on strength like and it's
totally the opposite of the last one so
crazy there's like now the big thing is
you know with intermittent fasting it's
like okay there's all these diets and
eat this and gluten that and all that
and then now the new diet is don't eat
for 18 hours
that should work
you know what's great about that is it
makes you have a time every day where
you can have the most fabulous meal ever
because when I when I eat I'm starving
[Music]
and salads taste so good and when you're
not when you're not that hungry it fit
now now I feel like if I'm not that
hungry I don't want to waste a meal
because it's so much better when you're
starving and you're out of control
yeah yeah I eat that way most of the
time except on days when I know I have a
really brutal workout in the morning
like a weightlifting work I'll run
fasted I'll do yoga fasted but if I'm
gonna lift I want to have something I
need I need some fruit or some it's
almost 3:00 right now I haven't eaten I
don't yeah I'm fine fine you know it's a
it's a it's some interesting diet I hope
that it isn't [ __ ] no it's
definitely not [ __ ] I was never a
morning person either like I never I
never really looked forward to breakfast
it was always at had have I got protein
bar or something just cuz I had to did
you ever listen to my podcast I did with
Dom de Augustin oh he's a scientist from
I think his University of Florida but a
ketogenic specialist does a lot of keto
research and research on fasting and the
benefits of fasting and he goes into the
scientific benefits
proven benefits of fasting very very
interesting stuff would it eat what
would that I would really want to direct
you to that I want to [ __ ] it up but
it's for the prevention of cancer
really yeah ketone bodies in the blood
increase cognitive improvements I just
think we eat too much
yeah it's thing we eat too much weird
all time so easy yeah I like watching TV
and snacking yeah watch a little Netflix
we all do